difficult game today I think you were
expecting maybe or hoping for a group
felt from mvl was that way he started
with one before
um yeah
um yeah Maxine please girlfriend most of
the times but today he chose very solid
line
and yeah I couldn't remember so much
also and I think the game was very
balanced but the plan coming in today's
round was definitely to put as much
pressure as possible right yeah yeah but
he played brilliantly I think we have an
age here because my Rook is on E1 but I
couldn't find the
way to get Advantage so he played Bishop
B5 which is very good move and I guess
there was nothing in the game
and I saw you towards there a bit
disappointed when you guys started
chopping everything off the board
um what are your initial feelings after
this tournament the conclusion of this
tournament yeah of course I'm very
disappointed with the yesterday game
it feels like the tournament was going
my way but yeah suddenly there was to do
the brilliant game and it was a very low
quality game but from his side it was
okay and
yeah it was just the opening problem
yesterday I couldn't remember the line
and I was worse the whole game then I
got chances but
um I was it was not enough to make it
throws so in overall I'm very happy
after
um the loss with Wesley in the first
round yeah to get plus one to finish
with plus one is pretty good so
um last year I got minus one here so
it's a good start to the year I think
definitely an improvement and in fact
you played Maxim uh in last year's last
round as well that didn't go your way
but today uh um much easier Day at the
Office alireza congratulations for a
decent result for sure not after your
standards but still quite decent after
analytical loss I'm satisfied with it
yes absolutely thank you very much
alireza and we'll see you in the next uh
tournaments thank you very much